[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 25 juillet 2015
pour louis et moi c'est le plus beau
jour de notre vie le 5 janvier 2016
le pire jour de notre vie entre la
naissance de notre fille ambre et 1 et
l'annoncent du premier diagnostic nous
vivons cinq mois d'insouciance de vie
quasi normale
nous l'en demande déjà partout avec nous
peut-être pour la préparer à ce tour de
monde que nous allons faire à 3 et puis
rapidement on comprend que quelque chose
ne va pas que notre vie ne sera pas
celle des autres
à ces dix mois le couperet tombe
et le verdict est sans appel andrea une
maladie génétique rare
neurodégénératives
peut-être que quand vous visionnerez
cette conférence l'année prochaine
machine ne sera plus à la 3 ans un petit
bébé ne devrait pas être malade un petit
bébé a toute la vie devant lui un petit
bébé deviendra grand
cette normalité tout imaginer ça arrêter
pour louis ya moins à ces cinq mois
finalement ça n'arrive pas qu'aux autres
ça nous arrive c'est maintenant je vais
vous confier un secret
avant j'étais comme vous j'étais
réticente
rien qu'à mettre du doliprane un enfant
qui fait ses dents aujourd'hui je
coordonne cinq pharmacies pour empire
larmande et ma fille
j'avais peur de lui couper ses ongles et
puis pendant quatre mois
chaque semaine je vais remis sa sonde
naso-gastrique et aujourd'hui je change
les prolongateurs de sa gastronomie
je me demandais quel veilleuse
montessori j'avais bien pouvoir lui
acheter
et puis me voilà la gué temps pour ne
pas qu'elle se réveille dans le tunnel
de l'irm le wiki cinq mois auparavant se
demandait comment porter son bébé pour
son premier bain se retrouver en train
d'essayer de là à tenir correctement
pour ne pas qu'elle bouge lors de sa
ponction lombaire les premiers jours
d'hospitalisation je veux parler à
personne je suis pas comme vous c'est
pas en train de m'arriver ma fille ira
bien elle jeudi à louis je veux pas
devenir un couloir un zombie du couleurs
de neurologie
je suis pas sorti de la chambre pendant
quinze jours je voulais pas louper le
passage des neurologues je suis pas
sorti de l'hôpital pendant 20 jours
j'ai dû prendre trois douches au total
finalement rapidement je le suis devenu
zombies de ceux qui hier d'assistante
sociale en assistante sociale dans le
brouillard d'acronymes mystérieux pour
faire reconnaître son bébé comme un
handicapé sans trop savoir pourquoi
en justifiant par des certificats
médicaux évolutif par la rédaction d'un
bien mal nommée projet de vie pour
espérer avoir la bonne allocation la
bonne place dans le bon établissement
dans la bonne crèche auprès du bon
professionnel de santé la bonne carte
invalidité la bonne carte mobilité
inclusion et puis tout refaire parce que
son dossier ait perdu et comprendre
rapidement très rapidement qu'à voir bac
+10 à 2 ne vous servira strictement en
riant dans ce monde à part pour
s'enfoncer comme tout le monde dans la
bien nommée errance administrative alors
comme tout le monde dans ce monde à part
on le rencontre le fameux professionnels
de santé maladroit
celui qui à minuit aux urgences regarde
votre bébé vous regarde vous l'un après
l'autre mais vous êtes de la même
famille vous devez vous trompez en fait
moi je viens pour un reflux gastrique
comme tout le monde dans ce monde à part
on l'a croisé le l'humain en mal de
sensations fortes
imaginez vous balader en poussette avec
votre fils quand soudain une dame surgit
comme je suis heureuse de vous voir
j'étais à la soirée l'autre jour j'ai
entendu votre histoire
c'est formidable c'est votre fille pas
le temps de répondre et se jettent sur
elle lui trifouille le ventre elle à son
tube pour la nourrir comme tout le monde
dans ce monde à part
on est fatigués et rentrent et tout ça
finie la liberté d'un apéro en sortie de
bureau
je peux pas andrea pleurs elle hurle
elle vomit beaucoup je peux pas la
laisser je viendrai la prochaine fois où
la suivante
finie la vie sociale les expos les suis
né les musées je peux pas j'ai hôpital
puis les week-ends improvisé les voyages
surprise
dommage on avait même le sac de rando
adapté pour le road trip l'été prochain
finie la carrière commence pôle emploi
on se transforme on s'abîme
on se demande même s'il faut pas mieux
se séparer comme 80% des parents de ce
monde à part
vous savez pour essayer de conserver au
moins une moitié de vie normal chacun et
finalement si on avait tout faux
lacan disait le réel c'est quand on se
cogne
nous on s'est cognée bien fort le real
on se l'ait pris pleine face andrea ne
marchera jamais elle ne mangera jamais
par la bouche elle nous appellera jamais
papa maman puisqu'elle ne parlera jamais
alors quoi abandonné
à quoi bon persévérer dans le même moule
puisque de toute façon dès l'annoncé du
premier diagnostic s'était déjà pu le
même donc pas le choix faut rebondir à
cette époque andré a souri encore la
faire sourire c'est notre moteur on va
aux irm en dansant sur michael jackson
pour les électroencéphalogrammes on
préfère david bowie à des feux des
séances d'éveil musical prévu à la
philharmonie de paris
on explore tous les sons et les chansons
possibles pour la distraire quand les
infirmières cherche sur ce tout petit
mans et c'est tout petit pied la bonne
veine pour la prise de sang parfois
pendant une heure sans succès j'ai très
tôt compris qui vaille mieux agir plutôt
que tergiverser bon mais dans dix mètres
carrés d'une chambre d'hôpital comment
agir eh ben pour tenir
j'ai pas trouvé mieux que le rêve le
rêve l'imaginaire celui qui vous permet
de vous échapper celui auquel vous
rattachez de plus en plus celui auquel
vous rattachez de plus en plus vos
lectures
j'avais envie d'air de nature j'ai donc
appris la permaculture dans les livres à
l'hôpital non sans mettre une seule fois
les mains dans la terre
j'ai appris les associations de culture
en même temps que les mots atrophie
dystonie mitochondries gastrostomie de
l'air ailleurs surtout ailleurs andré a
été un détonateur dans nos vies une
vraie bombe dévastatrice mais elle nous
pousse tous les jours à construire sur
nos friche perdre ses repères
c'est aussi l'occasion de son construire
de nouveau perdre son insouciance pour
gagner en résilience
c'est justement hors de notre zone de
confort que nous nous révélons la
maladie le handicap nous met au pied du
mur ils vous pendre ils vous poussent à
penser le monde autrement à désapprendre
à déconstruire tout ce que vous pensiez
soigneusement et durablement établi
vous devenez court termiste vous ne
planifiez plus tout ce que vous pensiez
n'est plus vous redevenez pur instant
alors quand tout est déjà père dieu de
toute façon vous pouvez acheter un corps
de ferme en ruine et c'est ce qu'on a
fait avec louis on a décidé de
redessiner le peu de temps cambria
passerait auprès de nous quand je me
projette deux ans en arrière quand je
nous revois acheté cette longère avec
andrea qui avait un an dont on ne savait
pas si elle sera encore avec nous à la
fin des travaux
je ne revois agir peut-être avec
l'énergie du désespoir mais certainement
plus avec celle de l'instant parce que
ce choix de vie ne peut se mesurer
raisonnablement en pesant le pour le
contre en mettant des plus des moins
dans des tableaux excel il tolère aucun
avis extérieur il fallait partir refuser
la chronique de la mort sociale annoncé
chercher une utilité sociale
refuser de s'écouler construire une
nouvelle vie cet ailleurs qui nous a
toujours donné envie et que qu'on
pouvait toucher si aisément du doigt
avant en prenant un billet d'avion pour
voguer vers d'autres horizons mais on a
vite compris que c'était terminé que la
nouvelle vie qui nous était imposé t2
fait liberticide
j'ai jamais pu me résoudre à cette
privation de liberté il fallait
absolument se construire ce nouvel
ailleurs dans ce nouveau schéma qui nous
était imposé il ya deux ans quand nous
avons quitté paris
on s'est retrouvé dans un village en
pleine campagne autant d'habitants dans
le village que dans les immeubles
mitoyens que nous avions laissé la
veille des pâtures à perdre de vue un
chat un chien un coq un cheval mais vous
savez quoi ça m'a fait un bien fou
contre l'agitation citadine et mon
tumulte intérieur qui faisait écho me
retrouver dans la nature dans le calme
et le verbe à apaiser ouvrir le champ
des possibles à la sérénité
c'est ce que nous voulons offrir à notre
tour pourquoi ça se demande pas ça se
vit quand les câlins à votre bébé ne
suffisent plus et qui vivent ou faux lui
administrer d'urgence un neuroleptique
je vous mets au défi de relire les
conseils de l'éducation selon d'alto
quand votre enfant peut hurler 15 heures
d'affilée je vous mets au défi de prenez
la bienveillance à la 16e heure c'est
comme ça qu'est née l'idée des bobos à
la ferme
les bobos à la ferme c'est notre projet
à bulles d'oxygène dans ce quotidien
anxiogène auquel on se refuse le sens
que nous décidons de donner à l'avis
d'andré on n'abandonne pas nos idéaux ou
les sublimes en créant ce projet de
coeur ce que nous créions plutôt ce que
nous essayons de créer c'est un lieu de
répit inclusif le répit s'essouffler
c'est faire une pause mais c'est aussi
un endroit le droit au répit qui est
inscrit dans la loi handicap 2005 pour
les aidants familiaux
les aidants familiaux ce sont ses 11
millions de personnes en france oui 11
millions qui s'occupent d'un proche en
perte d'autonomie handicap maladie
vieillesse dépendance
nous on a voulu s'appuyer dessus pour
créer des séjours de répit en milieu
touristique ordinaire n'est ce pas aussi
important que de scolariser les enfants
qui le peuvent en milieu ordinaire
alors chez nous les bobos des enfants
c'est à la ferme une nature omniprésente
des hébergements adaptés des
professionnels attentifs pour s'offrir
une pause hors de son espace temps pour
déconnecter de son quotidien et
reconnecter à la terre les enfants sont
des éponges et offrir à leurs parents un
cadre bienveillant pour les apaiser
c'est plus qu'essentiel c'est de la
bientraitance
on me demande parfois par rapport au
projet mais comment allez vous faire
pour accueillir des touristes normaux
avec des enfants handicapés
je me questionne est ce que quand vous
allez en vacances quand vous réserver
votre chambre d'hôtel vous appeler pour
savoir quel sera le genre l'orientation
sexuelle ou la couleur de votre voisin
est ce que avant la rentrée scolaire
vous appelez l'école pour savoir s'il y
aura un enfant handicapé dans la classe
de votre enfant
j'espère pas accepter l'inclusion s'est
refusé l'exclusion on m'a demandé
récemment comment passer de la folie à
la réalité sur ce projet c'est pas de la
folie la folie pour nous il était de
nous entêter dans notre vie d'avant avec
la survenue de la maladie d'andré ans
c'est pas facile je vous le dis tu perds
dû renoncer
dès lors je sais pourquoi c'est pas
facile parce que c'est un paragraphe qui
est très émouvant pour moi
dès lors que le handicap sens allant des
devis il bouleverse tout il bouleverse
le rapport à soir le rapport à l'autre
aile rapport aux autres il redéfinit vos
priorités
il y aura toujours un avant et un après
il est à un retour à l'essentiel une
purge à futilités un entonnoir qui
réduit peu à peu le champ des possibles
et vous dévoile se dévoile et s'est levé
le voile c'est voir par le prisme de
notre vulnérabilité de nos fragilités
c'est découvrir nos proches autrement et
eux aussi se révèle sa accueillir dans
nos vies de nouvelles personnes et
recevoir beaucoup d'amour
nos sentiments sont décuplés l'ascenseur
émotionnel nous fait monter très haut
quand on rêve va bien et nous plonge
dans des angoisses profondes
quand sa maladie progresse être à
l'écouté des signaux faibles garder
cette flexibilité quant à la réponse à
donner à la vie et à son imprévisibilité
c'est ce que nous apprend le handicap
tous les jours depuis trois ans andréa
nous révèle à nous mêmes elle nous
apprend la maîtrise de nous mêmes est
d'ailleurs très exigeante là dessus
depuis trois ans nous cheminons à ses
côtés moi aussi j'ai changé peu à peu
j'accepte avec notre association a même
créé les rendez-vous des parents
extraordinaire et on se réunit tous les
mois entre nous je discute je découvre
des histoires de vie incroyable des
parents qui ont perdu leur emploi
parfois tous leurs amis et qui sont
devenu administrateur de l'avis médical
de l'enfant coordinateur de leurs agents
administre auprès des professionnels de
santé experts de l'administration
française couteau suisse des solutions
qui n'existe pas les parents d'enfants
handicapés ont une force de vie et de
résilience insoupçonnées savez-vous
qu'une étude a prouvé que les mamans
d'enfants autistes ou un stress
équivalent à celui d'un soldat au combat
elle ne lâche jamais avec les bobeurs
les fermes on n'est pas une exception
savez vous que le handicap est une
source de créativité intarissable
les lunettes de soleil par exemple ont
été inventées à la base pour les
déficients visuels
les télécommandes pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite
les sms pour les personnes
malentendantes tous les jours le
handicap est à l'origine d'initiatives
et d'innovations impressionnante qui
méritent d'être mises en lumière parce
que tellement importante et utile à la
société dans son ensemble
je sais pas si j'ai ma place ici ce soir
je me sens pas dé calais je me sens
plutôt hors centre et plus aligné malgré
la survenue de la maladie d'ambré 1
j'ai l'impression qu'aujourd'hui plus
qu'hier on n il vient en accord avec
nous mêmes et avec nos valeurs andrea et
sur cette terre pour que vous fassiez ce
que vous faites
nathan dit récemment tous les jours mon
doute mais nous savons que nous n'avons
plus le choix on avance vers une
échéance qui nous bouleverse sera
définitivement et on ne sait pas comme
on en sortira mais en attendant on
construit et en attendant surtout on
continue à faire danser notre princesse
sur son fauteuil
merci
[Applaudissements]